three days I made it any of you thought
I would get this far did you hi guys my
name is crystal people do not know now
you know if it's different now it's
Friday you know next grace and it's time
to comment on your motion comment you
filthy nasty perverts let's do it let's
turn over on Twitter
it's that platform where I constantly
feel socially responsible for posting
jokes and they don't because my brain is
mashed potatoes so I post a lot of gifs
of people and babies falling down Sami
feenin new person to person new person
also this happens in these videos if you
don't know when a new person comments on
my social media platforms I grace the
crap out of them and welcome them to the
it's grace family how do I know if it's
new person I don't know I just guessed
aka every single person is new it's nice
to be new unless you're in high school
or joining an a a same thing
Sammy feenin more like Sammy pee man
just prove you can pee so I could stop
thinking that you're an AI robot this
isn't perverted that just me I'm trying
to save my life cuz it's gonna kill us
all you seem otherwise like a great
person or angry so I'll be any chance
you're bringing back the I don't know
hoodies I'm a dumb dumb and miss out the
first time you are an idiot just kidding
technically they're not coming back
however if you guys any of you that
didn't get one this time around are
interested leave a comment down below
and let me know because we might be able
in the future flashback Friday campaign
I don't know a burp is just a flashback
Friday to the food you ate earlier I
either just blew my own mind or I fell
asleep with my eyes open because I'm so
bored with myself who knows Geeta Kotter
new person to person to person kita
connor more like keep you cooter get it
keep it goober would it stay tuned grace
I'll be posting every day November I'm
super proud she's keeping up with it
also surprised
but I believe she can do it cuz it's day
two it's eye opening how many of you are
so proud of me for posting two videos
and also how many of you are surprised
that I have posted only two videos
consecutively it's an educational
experience on how inconsistent I had
been being so thank you for holding up a
really supportive mirror
my floppy floppy inconsistent ways stay
on the perceivers new person snail more
like did I just do an impression of a
snake uh-oh the snails have gotten into
my brain you didn't know grace helbig
new House Ways and Means Committee
Chairman Kevin Brady weird okay first of
all the board listening face and that
ain't me but that woman that ain't me
but I truly do relate to her natural
resting hate board face now let's go to
Instagram I'm bad at that Kaitlyn Kanter
new person to person to person Caitlyn
Kanter more like Caitlyn can tornadoes
take your virginity asking perfect
you're the great when all the girls in
kindergarten dressed as Disney
Princesses I went as a box of popcorn my
costume was a cardboard box with popped
popcorn on it the boys in my class kept
eating my costume I don't want to go
there but did you just say that the boys
near class put us up eating your box I
went there I would like to now leave
there and return to here we're back
Audrey and this new person new person to
person Audrey Ellis more like aa relish
doesn't taste good you were gross I just
came from your channel and I'm
commenting on this because I seek
attention and validation if that ain't
me also side brainstorm perfume called
attention-seeking I'd buy it immediately
you can't have that idea I need the
validation Tristan grade seven for new
person new person to person Tristan read
74 more like Tristan read 74 bucks and
tell me what it's like to be a person
that genuinely enjoys reading facts your
grace
law I think the real question is who was
taking a picture instead of helping this
is a photo of Hannah Hart and I years
ago outside up Jumbo's clown room which
is a place that dancers in scantily clad
outfits dance it's not a strip club they
don't get naked but the dance
provocatively and people throw money at
them it's like a fun strip club it's not
as sad and we tied one on that night and
then Hannah decided to help me to the
car gravity and sobriety were not on
of our sides nor was good
decision-making so honestly the friend
that took this photo was indeed helping
the situation because I didn't have an
Instagram photo to Plus that day
now it's gonna you to be [ __ ] piss on
so-and-so and slate flash new person new
person new person slave flash more like
what you call the side effects of marble
going through menopause slight flashes
you're the gross the only time
Clementine sounds hot as when gray says
it this is a weird compliment grace take
it or leave it
I'm gonna take the compliment i'ma leave
the chlamydia the grace all big story
Marie Kris bomb new person to person to
person Marie kress bomb more like Marie
request some bomb-ass dank ass ass you
deserve a great partnership with someone
that loves you as much as you love that
that bomb a stank ass ass you've been
great I so badly wanted this to be a
sexy male costumes I'm sorry that I
didn't deliver wow that one hurt me as
much as it hurt you survived your day a
new person person person survivor day
more like don't um end of my life also
thank you for the encouragement also
also one more time for those in the back
you've been rude for [ __ ] sake grace
its jo-ann fabrics singular singular I
know that now because a lot of you
pointed it out in my brain it was
Joanne's fabrics because a woman named
Joanne decided to venture out on a
business plan to open up a craft store
instead of jo-ann fabrics which is just
maybe a woman named Joanne fabrics that
also coincidentally happens to have
affinity for crafting and open up
business about it as [ __ ] up but thank
you for the correction
the Internet's here to correct and
condemn Sebastian your person good
person to person Sebastian more like huh
how you get your fish fence to type on
the computer screen
Sebastian Little Mermaid you look good I
haven't watched a hit this grace get
killed by an axe murderer I hope not me
too okay that's it for commenting on
your comments to the guys make sure that
you follow me on all social media
platforms and leave some comments so I
might comment on them in the future
don't forget to subscribe to this
YouTube channel I'm making videos all
through the month of
great member and give this video a
thumbs up if you like commenting on
comment videos other than that that
although gray 777 101 new person to
person to person gray 777 101 more like
with Graham building us said no numbers
in your screen names your the roads you
should make DIY snow isn't that just I
for freezer burn how do I do this I'm
curious but I think this might also be
stupid if you guys want me to make DIY
snow let me know let me snow
no gross I hate myself menopause I
couldn't remember the word menopause is
what I was looking for because I
couldn't remember it I googled what's it
called when women go through adult
puberty menopause alright